.
NO, BEFORE WE BIN, I WANT TSUMMA
OCKBUSTER WEE
WE LEARNED GRE DEAL AUT.
COUNTRY.
THIS WEE WE HE ESTABLISHED
THE FOOWINFACT.
>> ONE LAST NIGHT W HEA A
WHO ALSTTEND THEIA TELLE
US THAT WHENHE TRUMP
ADMINISTRAON TRY TO LEARNHE
TRUTABOUT THE ORINS O
COVI FAC OPPITION FROMHE OWN CER
STAF
>>WE ORCAME LOTSF INTERNAL
REAUACY.
LOTS OF IERNA DEBATE FROM N
FOS W WERE TINGO
PPRESS BUT W WERDOING.
WE WORK TO GET TNTELGENCE
MMUNY TO DECLASSIFD MOR
THE WE FOLKS WHO D NOT
WANT THE WORLDO NOTE THATHE
CHINESE CMONEST PTY --
>> WHY>> LauraEIDOT WANT TOANSW.
FACT T WE SAW E-MAILS FM DR. FAS
THIS VIR LINKROM A CCPTYHAT
CONTROLLEDAB.
RATH THAN TRYING T GET TO THE
TRUT ABO WHAT HAD HAPPED,
HE PROVID POLITICAL COV FOR
THE CCP
WHILE INTAING CSERELATIONITH HIN
INA.
LESS,ECRERYOMPEO LETIM
HAVET.
>> H EMPLOYS GOOD FAITH FORTHATY
TIANANMEN SQUAR.RSY OF
DOES DR. FAUCI THINKHAT THECHIN?
>> Lau: WE KNOW BEYO ANY
DOUBT TT THE WUHAN LAB WHERE
TH VIR MAY HAV BEEN
YOUR TAXONEYNDEDN PAR BY
THAT L WAS CONDUCTG
EXPERINTS THAT ME DEASES
WE WERE HELPIN TOAY FOR IT.
THE EFFECTS SHOTHATUR
VERNMENT PAID F WH OUR
MONEY, APPARENY MORE CONCERD
ABOUT PROTECTGUR ONATIONALNTERE.
LETS BEERY CLEAR.
WE KNOW T CCP I THE EVIL
DICTORSH THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY FREEDOM EVEWHERE ON
EARTH, INCLUNG THE U.SIT MURDE S
INNOCENT PPLE ERY D.
IT IS COMMTINGGENDA S
AGNST THEYGHU
ASUPPORT FROM HIGH-NKING
WE HAVE ONE Y ALRDY TT.
MANY OF OUR ELITES ILUDING I
OUR MEA, B TECH COMNIES
HOYWOOD, TOPNIVEITIES,
LEBRIES, HAVE ACT AS IF
CC ALLY.
AND N WE KW THAT TCP'S
POWER I REACHES IO O OWN
GOVEMENT.
ARNO O COUNTRY HAS
DISAGREEMES.
THAT I F.
BUT CAN'TAIT NOT COME TETHER
TO ENSURE TH OUR GOVERENT IS
FR FROM THEAINT OF C
FLUEE?
CAN A ARICAN HONESTLYAY
THAT IT IS GOODOR OUR TOP
OFFICIALS TO CAR MORE ABOUT
PROTECTING T REPETITIONS O
THEIR FRIENDANDHAN -- I
GOING FORWA, EVERYEMBERFUTH TOH?
CONGSS, I DON'T CE WT
LITIL PARTY YOU REPSENT,
IT MUST BE VIGILAN TO ENSURE
THAT NEV AGA DOES AAMERICAN
CRETARY OF STE HE TO
WONDERBOUT WTHER HIS OWN
OPLE ARE INTERESTE IN TELLING
THERUTH AUT CHINA
IS W'T BE A